ratcliffe was arrested five years ago
she tried to leave
iran she was charged with spying and has
been
in prison since her five-year sentence
is nearing its end but yesterday her
family
was told that she's facing a new charge
she has been followed she's at home with
her family at the moment big concern was
that potentially
she may have to go straight back to jail
uh richard ratcliff her husband is with
us she didn't have to do that
she didn't yes you're right so yesterday
she was taken in front of george
salabati who's the judge who've tried on
previous cases
um was told that second court case has
been revived
you're going to be in court again on
sunday um so yeah
i mean bad news it could have been worse
um when she was picked up in the morning
it was by
the revolutionary guard uh interrogators
who held her in solitary confinement
she spent all morning worried that she
was going to be taken back to prison so
at the end of the day she's back at her
mum's dad's this morning she's still at
mums and dads
we'll be in court on sunday um it's not
looking good but
but you know what's the charge charges
spreading propaganda against the regime
um which was the charge that was brought
out uh in 2017 in the autumn
um and then again in in may 2018
so it's been that second court case
that's been wearing in the background
that points was blamed on the
now prime minister when he was foreign
secretary um never came to court
about that you don't just sweep that
under the carpet so so it's so
the court case in fairness was was
invoked when nazney kim became eligible
for parole
to stop her being released um boris
johnson when he was former secretary
misspoken parliament that was pounced on
by the iranian authorities the
journalist
said that she was in iran uh training
journalist when she was on holiday
that was used to justify the court case
um rhetorically a lot we never knew what
was being said in the court room because
they kept
postponing or postponing in fairness he
went to iran
uh court case got dropped made some
promises didn't deliver them
court case got revived then it got
stopped and it's been sort of
a whole game of cat and mouse and and us
being a political bargaining chip for a
long time
um we were as you said getting close to
the end of nazine's sentence
early march it should end um and you
know i was worrying and behind closed
doors were saying to the foreign office
i think
you know you can't just wait if we get
close to the end and we haven't solved
the issues and you aren't making it
clear to iran it's not okay
there's every chance that they'll revive
this case and indeed they have
and the trial the trial is on sunday
that could happen very that reached a
conclusion very quickly
so who knows is the honest answer what's
happened in in nazis previous trials is
the hearing doesn't that last that long
no one can get there i mean actually
we've asked the british
embassy to really try and get someone in
there to ask formally
legal letters that nova ballot is called
and then to try and go there to see if
they can go in and just keep it honest
the hearings before a couple of hours
they've lasted no verdict for a few
weeks
so um i would expect it with a similar
model so she'll go there some
something will happen we'll then not
know what what it means does it mean
a big long sentence a small center every
time we've been in court we've been
convicted
i would expect the same thing will
happen again but but the extent of how
many years get added
isn't clear at this point so what are
the what's the possibility
i mean who knows is the honest i i don't
think we're talking another 10 years
um but but we certainly could be talking
you know another couple of years
um i mean i i part of it clearly it
feels to me
it's putting political pressure on the
british government it's signaling that
this is a political
you know a need for the uk to engage and
nazi's being held as a bargaining chip
it probably candidly depends on how the
uk responds as to how far
the iranian regime will push up we owe
the iranians the shed load of money
don't we
um we've said that we're not going to
give it to them but it does look as
though there's
some weakening on that yes so so that's
right i mean
if i'm honest i think naznen was picked
up in the first place to get that money
uh there was a um
this is money that we owe because this
is this is money that the uk owes
um iran going back to an arms deal that
was done in the 1970s that then fell
apart after the revolution
big long battle about how much
compensation needed to be paid back and
so on
in the end it went to court and there
was a court award which was then held up
payment uh due to sanctions over time
that's become an increasingly bad
tempered
relationship and then to the point where
yeah we were taken hostage
um and have been held ever since um
you're right
the the new current defense secretary
ben wallace
wrote a letter to our lawyers um a
couple of weeks back saying listen
his personal view was that the money
should be paid um that's the first time
we've ever received a letter
several hundred million isn't it yes 400
million um so so proper money
um and certainly um been you know
long enough for us to be held over it
and your view is that if that money was
paid that
that your wife would be back home in the
uk look there are obviously parallel
issues
um my view is that if the money was paid
would make it an awful lot easier for
them
to be home um and the government would
say we don't pay for hostages
british governments got british
government has a difficult situation to
deal with
um and and obviously it needs to take a
responsible view
both for protecting those who are
currently being held and for protecting
those from not being taken
its current approach is basically not to
move and not to promote the iranian
response and all what's happened is
we've been held others have been taken
at the weekend there were threats
towards uh you know a new british
embassy staff member
um that's not working and it's really
not working so
behind closed doors we said of course
it's it's carrot and stick you need to
be having clear consequences in any
regime for holding british citizens
hostage
there has to be consequences that
otherwise yes they'll carry on doing it
but at the same time you do need to
address the underlying issues and you
know it's tough on hostage taking a bit
tough on the causes of it
you have spoken directly with the prime
minister both when he was prime minister
and also previously when he was foreign
secretary and how much involvement has
he had in in the case of late
uh so so um he wrote a letter to nazanin
not that long ago
um she she'd knitted um his new baby
uh woolly hat he pledged a thank you
letter um
and you know and i think that's that
personal connection and most of our
contacts
he actually said that it really moved
him and he moved into tears
and that his government would do all
they could to get her home um
most of that contact obviously is with
the foreign secretary uh dominic rabb
and he has spoken to nazarene he's
spoken to me um
he said that listen we're going to be
doing a diplomatic push and you know
trying to get her home
um i was reasonably skeptical that that
what they were trying was going to work
and and
you know we'll pick that conversation up
behind closed doors to say listen
it doesn't feel that we're in a good
place how is she
yeah okay i mean kind of as you said at
the beginning she she
was really daunted about being put back
into prison relieved yesterday
after court that she wasn't back in
prison and then as the day went on
reflecting more on the enormity of what
lay ahead and actually
kind of what for her what the worst case
scenario was it's five years and i'll be
home in
in in march now looking like it might be
a lot longer
how's the baby gabriella settled into
school yeah so so
really glad to be back as i'm sure you
know six-year-olds throughout the
throughout the country are um you know
much more funny baby because she's your
baby i know
and yeah so every single night she's a
big girl as well she's concerned um
but yes i think um you know glad to be
back at school
didn't really understand what she knew
mummy had a tough day yesterday
picked up on the fact we were stressed
and she was being a bit neglected and so
you know we had a few fraught moments
yesterday but
but she still lives in the you know the
moment of enjoying life in the here and
now
and how are you doing yeah okay i mean
yesterday was tough
and and it'll be a bumpy few days i
think
for us we need to see what happens on
sunday what happens in the courtroom
you know can the british government get
in there or not um
so i think it it's yeah it's a bit wait
and see and not
let myself feel it too much until we
know really where we are we know that
they watch the show in downing street a
thought
for the prime minister yeah i mean just
just i think
i think there is a need for rethink
there is clear signaling happening
to the british government about what
they need to do and and they do need to
look
very carefully at how they protect
people okay it's good to talk to you um
do keep in touch anything we can do at
all let us know thank you thank you as
always